i think the show is fantastic
and you guys both do such great work and
i have a lot of questions about it but i
have to
do an individual question for paul first
if you don't mind just because i'm a
huge fan of aliens
and i just need to know um from you know
uh that was early in your career and i'm
just curious if you could
share a little bit of what it was like
making that film and working with
cameron
you know you'd never guess that you were
a fan of aliens just by your backdrop
there
uh there's every indication that you
live in the real world but
interesting
[Music]
i have there is a world by the way you
know i said
you know if you know the people who
really live and breathe aliens and i did
not know but
i was so thrilled to be in it it's a
wonderful great movie
but there's a subculture of people who
have all the things
and the props and and i met a guy said
i've seen that movie every saturday for
34 years
whoa i said okay you've got to get out
of the house
you got to call your parents you got to
do because they're worried about you
um you know my job it's a rare thing
to read a script and you know you can
see the movie
and aliens were so well written and and
jim cameron who had only done
i think terminator and like one other
movie but he was clearly
pretty brilliant and i read the script
and went oh this is going to be a
huge hit and it's gonna be really good
my job is to
not muck it up just if i can be a little
cog in the wheel and not bring the wheel
to a grinding halt
and uh so that's you know that was my
that was the standard i was going for
i set the bar low but it was it was
exciting and
as i say you know it's going to be good
and it was
i didn't realize how uh long
its legacy was i mean people still
really really really
live that film i've met a few people
who've still lived that film
uh and i think if you really want to see
it firsthand go to comic-con
when that reopens but one of the things
about aliens is the great writing which
leads me to the kaminsky method and
chuck laurie's great writing
i think i think that while all of you
guys deliver such great performances
it really is chuck's dialogue that
elevate this to to another level can you
both talk about working
with him and just the quality of his
writing i mean
he knows what he's doing you know he
doesn't need he doesn't even
say that um and but you know but i think
he feels he really stretched himself
with the kaminsky method too because
he's used to working
in you know multi-cam comedy format
and this is something different where
there were a lot of different things he
could play with um he could play with
something as simple as the amount of
time he had you know
it didn't have to be 22 and a half
minutes or whatever it is now
it could be 30 minutes it could be 40
minutes if we needed it to be a little
longer
um and just playing with single camera
no audience like this was all stuff that
was
um a newer challenge to chuck which i
think he embraced and i think
he enjoyed um bringing that
uh the drama in too you know it isn't a
joke a minute type of show i mean it's
hopefully a funny show but it's
um there's a lot of heart to it and
there's a lot of
um you know big serious issues that
we tackle on the show and and in this
case you know
chuck had the whole um pandemic to write
so he he wrote all six episodes
you know him alone at his house um
and so we went into the season having
having
all the episodes written and got to just
know exactly where
the stories and all of our characters
were going so it was i think what also
makes it
really work and i'm gonna guess was a
real treat for chuck is that he's
writing from a very real place that
here's a guy
in his upper 60s writing about guys in
their upper 60s and beyond
and so the the the goal of the show
wasn't let's get the most laughs let's
or let's keep writing a show that will
get us 9 10 11 seasons
the goal was let's talk about what this
is what is it like to be aging what is
it like to have
perhaps your best years behind you and
hopefully some good years ahead of you
what is it like to have
you know to look at guy friendship you
know ellen arkin and michael douglas
relationship that's an odd
clumsy world to dig into because guys
are not great at being friends
so i think the fact that chuck laurie
got to write
from his heart and and let a lot of
things out and his frustration
um with all of that was probably very
cathartic
i have to ask you paul about your
judgment
on barry levinson as an actor not as a
director
he's great you know it's so funny
because he
you watch him you go he shouldn't be
that good
uh but he's been i mean he's been on
camera a lot i mean
rain man he was yeah therapist and and
uh
and high anxiety he was here's your
paper
here's a paper um
and that was that was sort of mind
trippy um for me
just like you know barry that was my
very first job
ever dipping my feet in the
in the business was getting cast by
barry and diner
and then they ended up watching diner
it's just such a surreal
thing um yeah it was just i i just kept
smiling like this has been a long crazy
journey that i want to set
40 years later with barry
and and and it's about michael getting a
break in a big movie
by marrying one i can't even get my head
around all the
surrealness of this i gotta stop there
i'm just gonna say
thank you both so much and seriously
great work on this season
uh it's so good good luck with you yeah
let me see your collection there
thank you have a good day